[Music]
women and men face double standards no I
don't mean just the gender pay gap I'm
also talking about the different words
we use to describe men and women with
the same characteristics while he is
described as charismatic she's often
described as bubbly or vivacious you
wouldn't describe him as an airhead
he's just simple she's an airhead she's
bossy he's assertive women are far more
likely than men to be described as
gossiping if you don't believe me after
this film try a Google Images search for
gossip
unlike French German Spanish polish
practically any other European language
English doesn't have gender inherent and
most of its words but some of those
words become gendered anyway when we
choose different words to describe men
and women feisty is a classic example
it's rare to hear a man described as
feisty sure you could hear about a
feisty boxer but it's a lot more likely
to describe a flyweight than a
heavyweight
that's why some women here feisty is
implying a kind of figurative or literal
smallness in them and has a note of
condescension academics from the
University of Illinois and the
University of California and analyzed
over a hundred thousand works of fiction
written between 1800 and 2010 they
identified words connected to male or
female characters and the actions they
perform the study showed that the word
house used to be a strongly male term in
the 1800's house was associated with the
landed gentry in the Victorian era but
as the 20th century wore on house became
a slightly more female term associated
with domesticity the writer Ben Blatt
found that the verbs most associated
with the pronoun she' in classic fiction
are shivered wept murmured screamed and
married the most commonly associated
with he are muttered grinned shouted
chuckled and killed
an algorithm used by those academics who
studied house tries to determine that
characters gender based only on the
language used in descriptions in
dialogue these predictions were right 75
percent of the time for books written
around 1800 but that falls to just about
65 percent of the time in books written
around 2000 in other words the
vocabulary used to describe women and
men is becoming more blurred for the
gender stereotypes like feisty are less
common than they used to be nearly all
words have different shades of meaning
while the speaker intends the positive
one the hearer often hears the negative
bump that's a good reason to avoid
compliments that convey a note of
surprise Lane you are so articulate
really scouring your mind for evocative
language isn't easy but working hard to
be original and to avoid giving unwanted
offence it can only be a good thing
[Music]
you